Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis à la maison et il y a Laurent Tardieu qui est venu pour m'interviewer.
L'idée aujourd'hui Laurent, c'est un truc que j'ai jamais fait, je suis pas certain de réussir à le faire...
Mon but c'est de trouver ton code de carte bleue.
Un code pin tu le choisis toi-même. Ton code de carte bleue c'est que le code de carte bleue tu le choisis pas, il est imposé par la banque.
Est-ce que ça te fait stresser ou pas ?
Un petit peu ?
Laurent - Je...
Fabien - Est-ce que tu me fais confiance ?
Laurent - Je te fais entièrement confiance.
Fabien - On va faire un truc dans un premier temps...
Je vais... Je vais écrire des nombres et des chiffres ici
Laurent - Oui...
Fabien - Toi tu vas penser au premier numéro de ta carte bleue, c'est tout.
Et quand je vais l'écrire, le premier numéro de ta carte bleue, tu dis "stop" dans ta tête.
Laurent - Que dans ma tête ?
Fabien - Oui.
Donc toi tu regardes ici et moi je te regarde toi.
On est dans le champ ? Oui.
Là j'écris 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 0
Imagine le code est devant toi... Est-ce que ça finit par un nombre pair ?
C'est dur hein de pas bouger ?
Laurent - Eh je bouge pas là !
Fabien - Non...
Mais moi j'ai lu ton "non", t'inquiète pas.
Laurent - (rire)
Je sais que ça finit par un chiffre impair
Laurent - Oui...
Fabien - D'ailleurs ça peut être un chiffre fort ou un chiffre bas
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Ça peut être très haut ou très bas et... c'est très haut, merci !
Laurent - Mais putain ! (rires)
Fabien - Je pense que j'ai à peu près tout ce qu'il me faut.
On arrive à la difficulté de prouver que je pense connaître au moins... trois chiffres sur les quatre.
Je peux pas leur dire et te demander si c'est bon.
Et si je te fais lire sur un bout de papier ça fait un peu fake.
Il y a un distributeur à côté de chez moi
Si ça te dit on y va ? J'essaye de retirer 20 euros avec ta carte.
Laurent - Ah bah ouais ! Direct !
Fabien - C'est bon ? Aller, on est partis.
Je vous emmène avec moi c'est parti.
J'ai juste jusque là alors ?
Laurent - Je dis rien !
Fabien - (rire)
Laurent vient de me dire que sa carte expire en janvier 2017
Donc si j'ai le bon numéro, je pense qu'il ne va plus jamais essayer de me croiser jusqu'à janvier 2017
Laurent - Plus jamais !
Par rapport au réaction du 4éme, je pense qu'ils se suivent.
Je pense
comme dans 1.2.3.4.5.6.7.8
Regarde le il veux plus venir
Je regarde plus, je dis plus rien
Y'a une petite banque en face,c'est parfait pour nous.
C'est tout a fait ce qu'il nous faut.
On a un petit distributeur ici
Est ce que tu peux sortir ta carte bleue s'il te plait ?
Je la prends j'essaie de retirer 20 euros
et si ca marche pas c'est qu'il n'y a pas de billet.
C'est ça ! Je te propose de te reculer un petit peu pour que tu puisses me filmer avec la caméra, comme ça on verra si ça marche ou pas
et sans voir le code quoi
ça marche ?
y'a 3 essais hein ?
y'a 3 essais
Donc au pire je peux en essayer 2 si jamais.
il va me bloquer ma carte.
Là tu as le retour écran.
...manipulations...
c'est bon ?
Il faut que j'appuie sur rien ? non non je l'ai laissé tourner en boucle (plan séquence)
...manipulations...
Carte bleue. Non. argh ! Et 20 € *rire* mais comment ? Tiens. Je prouve que je rends l'argent et la carte bleue à Laurent
Et tu as mon code à vie ?
Oui!
Je vais aller déchirer ma carte bleue
Je vais faire opposition direct
C'est un malade !
Si un jour, il t'arrive quelque chose tu sais à qui t'en prendre.
Oui oui
JE PROMETS SOLENNELLEMENT DE NE JAMAIS DIRE TON CODE DE CARTE BLEUE, par contre je l'écrirai dans les commentaires.
Haha c'est ça, non je démentirai ce ne sera pas le mien.
Si vous vous abonnez à la chaine, au moment où vous cliquez sur le bouton "abonnement "instantanément vous recevez le code de Laurent Tardieu.
Vous irez pas loin ça va. Merci Laurent de ta confiance. Je suis sur le cul.
Tu repasses à la maison ? Bah ouais. Allez on retourne à la maison.
Tu as tes affaires là-bas.
Je vais prendre mes affaires et partir avec ta carte bleue. Là je suis sur le cul, comment tu peux ?
Bah écoute 72 24 c'est pas compliqué *tais toi* C'est pas ça, ne croyez pas a ça. Ne lui tendez pas un guet-apens . Si ça t'a plu ça coûte 20 balles.
Merci en tout cas à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. N'hésitez pas à faire un tour sur le blog : "une petite pièce s'il vous plait" que tient Laurent. Ça parle de pièces de spectacle mais pas que.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description. Tu veux deviner mon code d'entrée ? non mais c'est ouvert la journée.
C'est ouvert la journée
Pour les sous-titres si vous voulez participer je suis en train d'ouvrir la possibilité de sous-titrer toutes les vidéos..
c'est collaboratif, donc ça ne dépend que de vous en fait.
Ça permettrait que les malentendants puissent suivre les vidéos voire les gens qui ne parlent pas français
c'est à vous de voir, on se retrouve soit en spectacle soit sur le mental vlog.
Et la prochaine vidéo, c'est demain à 17h. Ciao!
...outro...